bonjour mes chers collègues je suis
vraiment très heureuse de saluer notre
collègue Stéphane Artano qui est
président de la négation
sénatoriale aux outre-merges vraiment le
remercier d'avoir accepté cette cette
invitation
puisque au-delà de l'actualité
on va dire extrêmement visible
de séjour sur la Polynésie que ce soit à
Mayotte que ce soit en Polynésie je
pense que
nous souffrons en tout cas moi c'est non
seulement le sentiment mais
l'enseignement que je dégageais n'étant
pas du tout une spécialiste des
Outre-mer en dehors de l'île de Sein ou
de Ouessant en Bretagne ce qui est une
forme quand même de positionnement
ultramarin je
je sentais quand au Sénat en abordait
ces sujets une vraie difficulté
par une absence de connaissance donc une
absence de compréhension et parfois ce
qui pouvait être soit des intérêts en
disant je l'ai aux gens qui savent
la comment dire la préoccupation
soit une sorte de désintérêt et on se
rend compte de l'importance des
outre-mer pour notre pays les autres
mères c'est la France la France est
aussi les autres mères et que on voit
bien aujourd'hui qu'il y a un contexte
géopolitique extrêmement on va dire
extrêmement puissant avec des forces qui
émergent et qui sont extrêmement
intéressés cultivent un certain appétit
pour certains de nos territoires
d'outre-mer et qu'il y a au sein des
Outre-mer sans des expressions des
appétences et un certain nombre de
difficultés que nous ne pouvons
ignorer alors la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales et traité
territorial et métropolitaines voilà
mais je pense qu'il faut qu'on s'ouvre
ouais mais nous avons toutefois avec
Jean-Michel Houlgate et Agnès canaillé
effectuait il y a maintenant un peu plus
d'un mois Jean-Michel un mois et demi
peut-être
à la demande du président Larcher et de
notre collègue la nature tenue une
mission en Polynésie sur
l'intercommunalité et nous avons pris là
conscience d'un certain nombre de sujets
de réalité
physique dans en Polynésie qui est un
territoire vaste comme l'Europe
faite dilo avec une organisation
territoriale qui n'a rien à voir avec la
nôtre un certain nombre de difficultés
et que on voit là qu'il y a sans doute
des évolutions qui sont nécessaires
parce que des organisations qui avaient
été décidées voilà un certain nombre
d'années
nécessite sans doute aujourd'hui de
peut-être un peu toiletté et qu'en tout
cas elle nécessite d'être
effectivement réalisé qu'on se rend
compte que on y trouve des sujets comme
la décentralisation la différenciation
la déconcentration et notre échelle mais
que ces réalités sont aussi les notes et
donc le président l'archet a souhaité
que dans ce groupe de travail est
communique qu'on m'a appelé
décentralisation mais qui couvre aussi
d'autres huiles il y a un volet
outre-mer ce qui est une idée que je
trouve judicieuse et donc hier le
président Artano a présenté à ce groupe
le résultat des travaux de la délégation
pour ma part
ça a été un apport considérable une
grille de lecture pour comprendre les
choses
telles qu'elles existent telles qu'elles
peuvent se présenter des sources aussi
de complexité on voit bien que si les
questions sont facilement identifiables
les réponses sont toutes leurs
complexité et qu'il m'a semblé fort
intéressant
que le président Artano Vienne en
quelque sorte nous livrer échanger avec
nous là-dessus je ne serai pas plus
longue et je suis sûr que notre collègue
Jean-Michel loca aura sans doute des
gens un peu plus précise sur la
Polynésie il y aura de toute façon à la
délégation présentation du rapport avant
l'été de cette mission Polynésie je ne
serai pas plus longue chers président et
cher Stéphane
[Musique]
sécurité il faut bien avoir à l'esprit
que tout ça vient déjà de travaux qui
ont été engagés par le Sénat en 2020
puisque le Sénat a déjà fait 50
propositions pour un nouvel acte de
décentralisation que dans cet acte
décentralisation il y avait évidemment
un volume ultramarin qui avait été porté
par Michel Magra qui avait porté
essentiellement mais pas que
essentiellement de préconisations qui
avaient été reprise mais il a eu
plusieurs dont ce rapport notamment
l'adaptation des normes nationales au
caractéristiques des territoires et puis
une réécriture des articles 73 et 74 qui
concerne les deux grandes catégories
d'outre-mer présent dans la Constitution
et en réalité
le président de la République a quand
même fait une déclaration en disant que
il y aurait une révision
constitutionnelle notamment eu égard au
contexte au calédonien la question c'est
donc posée au sein de la délégation de
réinterroger finalement le travail que
nous avions effectué en 2020 pour voir
s'il était pertinent d'actualité
nécessaire ou pas ceux qui
souhaiteraient évoluer de se rappeler
quand même que dans tout ça l'actualité
a fait qu'il y a eu l'appel de
Fort-de-France signé en mai 2022 par 7
executif qui a appelé à une évolution
institutionnelle le président de la
République a réuni l'ensemble des élus
ultramarins le 7 septembre 2022 à
l'Élysée en se montrant relativement
ouvert d'ailleurs sur ces perspectives
institutionnelles de manière générale
avec une feuille de route qui a été
dressée par le ministre d'armanin et
karenko avec un mode opératoire
territoire par territoire pour préparer
ce qu'on appelle maintenant le Conseil
interministériel aux outre-mer le scium
qui est attendu comme le messie mais qui
n'en est pas un il faut être lucide
c'est bien connu mais le ministre le dit
avec beaucoup de beaucoup de sincérité
je le pense et puis il y a eu évidemment
depuis 2020 un renouvellement de
certaines assemblées dans nos
territoires ultramarins et donc un
changement de vision et on en a eu un
dimanche qui va impacter
vraisemblablement le positionnement au
niveau
de institutionnel on le voit déjà
d'ailleurs au travers du programme
politique qui a été retenu donc voilà un
peu le contexte dans lequel les travaux
se sont inscrits en automne 2022 avec
macora porteur Michelin Jack c'est une
matrice de Saint-Barthélémy nous avons
donc auditionné tous les exécutifs de
l'outre-mer
[Musique]
et donc avec misting Jack nous avons
tiré plusieurs enseignements de nos
travaux le premier c'est qu'il y a eu
plusieurs consensus quand même qui sont
dégages une adaptation est suffisante
des politiques publiques aux réalités de
chaque territoire une faible efficacité
de plusieurs dispositifs de en vigueur
qui était censés normalement permettre
une meilleure adaptation des politiques
publiques je parle par exemple des
habitations législatives en gros ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que les correctifs
ne fonctionnent pas et puis un constat
sur l'état c'est un état déconcentré de
manière générale dans nos outre-mer qui
est trop rigide et surtout trop faible
s'il fallait synthétiser j'ai envie de
dire plus de décentralisation et plus de
déconcentration également serait
certainement une dualité intéressante de
manière générale et c'est sans doute le
sens profond finalement de l'appel de
Fort-de-France en mai 2022 il y a comme
une espèce de sentiments d'être arrivée
au bout d'un système
donc ce constat sur les échecs
l'adaptation
se traduit aussi une forte demande de
co-construction des politiques publiques
par nos territoires faire avec l'État
j'ai envie de dire et presque autant
demander que faire à la place de l'État
et ce constat partagé pour autant et
vous l'avez dit cher Françoise ne permet
pas de dégager des solutions communes et
j'ai envie de dire que on soit ça n'est
pas si choquant que ça puisque c'est
l'expression pleine et entière de ce
qu'est la différenciation
son ça on serait sur une forme de pensée
unique et ce serait de la négation même
de des réalités de chacun de nos
territoires
alors les collectivités de l'article 74
ne sont pas forcément demandeuses de
profondes évolution donc 74 c'est
Polynésie Saint-Barth Saint-Martin
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
elle parle plus d'aménagement à la marge
elle sont globalement satisfaites de
leur statut la grande majorité des
souhaits d'évolution d'ailleurs exprimés
n'appellent pas directement de
modification de la Constitution
puisqu'elle dispose toutes de loi
organique et que bien souvent ça passe
par la loi organique mise à part pour la
Polynésie française où il y a une
demande forte et récurrente
d'inscription dans la loi fondamentale
du fait nucléaire voilà donc ça c'est un
sujet évidemment à part et de fait de
donner la valeur législative aux lois du
pays
donc certaines dispositions de l'article
74 pourrait selon nous néanmoins être
précisé le contenu attaché notamment la
notion de collectivité dotée de
l'autonomie c'est vrai qu'on confond
souvent autonomie indépendance c'est pas
du tout la même chose et la cette notion
d'autonomie pourrait être renforcée pour
la clarifier enfin à propos d'un projet
de refonte global du cadre constitution
des Outre-mer qui mettrai un terme à la
dichotomie d'homme comme ou Drom com
certaines collectivités de l'articles se
sont exprimées contre Saint-Martin et la
Polynésie française donc Édouard Fritz à
l'époque
les autres demeurent plutôt ouvertes
Saint-Barth saint-permitton on se dit
que nous c'est une réécriture ça ne nous
pose pas de difficultés fondamentales
dans la mesure on ne nous enlève rien
par rapport à l'existant donc c'est à
dire qu'on nous permet toujours le champ
des possibles qui existent aujourd'hui
pour les collectivités d'articles 73 ça
devient un peu plus sportif puisque là
les orientations sont très diverses à
voir parfois opposées vous avez d'un
côté la Guyane et la Martinique dans une
dans une moindre mesure qui ont exprimé
une volonté de fortes évolution elle
souhaite en particulier un pouvoir
normatif plus fort dans de nombreux
domaines de compétences or le statut
actuel de l'article 73 les en empêche la
Guyane va elle plus loin en demandant
une mention particulière dans la
Constitution qui garantirait son
autonomie
en revanche le basculement vers
l'article 74 n'a pas du tout été formulé
par les collectivités de l'article 73
et puis de l'autre côté vous avez
Mayotte et le département de La Réunion
qui eux sont attachés au statu quoctuel
article 73 articles 74 le département de
La Réunion il y a une histoire
évidemment déjà ancienne souhaite le
maintien de l'amendement Virapoulé alors
que la région de La Réunion souhaite sa
suppression donc vous pouvez déjà que
sur le territoire on n'est pas forcément
tout à fait en phase et ça peut se
comprendre pour des raisons de vision et
d'avenir du territoire vraisemblablement
et puis de passer historique un
partenariat renouvelé avec l'État
mettant l'accent sur la co-construction
des politiques publiques et de
consultation appuyer en amont on se rend
compte souvent qu'on est consulté
quasiment au bout du bout du processus
législatif toutefois la région la
Réunion est donc favorable à cette
suppression et plutôt ouverte à de
nouvelles compétences donc on voit bien
qu'on a la deux visions qui qui
s'opposent sur le territoire entre les
deux il y a la Guadeloupe qui est
ouverte à des évolutions
sans position de principe affirmé
néanmoins en groupe décentralisation
hier notre collègue Dominique Théophile
nous a nous a évoqué les positions
arrêtées par la Guadeloupe de manière
tout à fait récente en fait donc à
l'époque où nos auditions ont eu lieu le
département de la Guadeloupe avait une
certaine vision mais le président de la
Région n'avait pas encore formulé ses
propositions puisqu'il souhaitait que le
Congrès continue de se réunir et fasse
et propositions elles viennent tout
juste d'arriver donc vous voyez que
c'est un sujet qui est quand même très
très mobile et très très volatile et qui
bouge beaucoup donc c'est bidons des
auditions a conduit à délégation à
formuler trois scénarios on a essayé de
trouver une ligne de crête si jamais une
évolution constitutionnelle ou
institutionnelle arrivée parce que ce
que je dis comme précaution d'usage et
on l'a également dit hier c'est que
pour nous et pour avoir été président de
collectivité j'ai envie de dire que le
volet institutionnel il arrive au bout
du bout de ce qu'on devrait faire c'est
à dire que on arrive à toucher les
institutions quand on n'a pas réussi à
répondre à nos problèmes de population
sur nos territoires avec tous les outils
déjà existants je pense qu'il faut bien
le mettre comme ça
on ne fait pas de cette évolution
constitutionnelle ou institutionnelle
une espèce de totem auquel on s'accroche
absolument on s'imaginant que c'est
l'alpha et l'oméga c'est pas tout à fait
comme ça que les travaux ont été
construits aujourd'hui le président de
la République en tout cas il y a
maintenant plus d'un an au frais une
perspective constitutionnelle possible
il y en a une tous les 15 20 ans donc on
se dit que si pour certains ça passe par
une évolution constitutionnelle il
serait dommageable de ne pas en profiter
et pour ceux qui ne voudraient pas
bouger à la rigueur mais ne bougerait
pas dans l'absolu si le souhait était
celui-ci donc le premier scénario qu'on
a qu'on a imaginé c'est le statu quo
constitutionnel c'est le entre
guillemets le statut le plus simple le
plus conservateur aussi
mais qui exigerait néanmoins selon nous
que l'État réinterroge quand même ces
méthodes d'élaboration des lois et des
décrets en effet et c'est un terme qu'on
a utilisé également hier une révolution
des méthodes nous semblent
indispensables c'est d'ailleurs quelque
chose un peu emprunter à la délégation
collectivité sur le volet des normes sur
lequel vous avez récemment travaillé
quel que soit d'après nous les scénarios
qui doivent être retenus cette réforme
des méthodes elle doit être transversale
je pense que ce que nous proposons là et
ce qui peut être imaginé par d'autres à
mon avis de régider l'action publique de
manière générale quel que soit les
scénarios on a imaginé 6 pistes elles
sont pas exhaustives et on n'a pas le la
prétention d'avoir le monopole de la
pensée sur ce sujet la principale serait
de créer une semaine consacrée chaque
année aux outre-mer au Parlement au
cours de laquelle une loi annuelle
d'adaptation serait examinée issue d'un
projet de loi ou un défaut d'une
proposition des travaux de contrôle
pourraient ainsi être menés par les
parlementaires ça figurait déjà dans les
recommandations arrêtées par le Sénat en
2020 donc j'ai presque envie de on m'a
pas réinventé on considère que cette
semaine là a pleinement son intérêt le
ministre qui a un covoyant d'ailleurs
nous annoncer hier à l'issueum il avait
vraisemblablement la volonté d'avoir une
grande loi outre-mer donc on se
rapproche quelque part de d'une espèce
de philosophie qui dirait qu'on aurait
une loi annuelle qui permettrait de
balayer de nettoyer finalement ce qui
doit l'être le deuxième la deuxième
piste concerne les études d'impact donc
un gros travail évidemment mais je vous
apprends rien reste à faire pour que
l'adaptation des dispositifs aurait été
des Outre-mer soit examinés dès la
laboration des avants projets de loi et
de décret et non à la toute fin c'est à
ce stade que des études d'impact des
collectivités de travail devraient être
consultés et d'ailleurs j'ai demandé
hier au ministre caraco de faire une
étude d'impact sur son projet droit
outre-mer ce serait à mon avis la preuve
par exemple
et je pense que ces services sont tout
aussi favorables à faire en sorte de
pouvoir avoir une étude d'impact sur le
projet de loi qui serait présenté ce
serait sans doute une première entre
guillemets en ce qui concerne nos
territoires la deuxième serait une revue
générale des normes outre-mer code par
code on l'a fait en 96 avec le code des
pêches et d'agriculture c'est un Conseil
d'État monsieur maire à l'époque qui s'y
était collé qui avait fait un travail
remarquable territoire par territoire et
vraiment on imagine que cette revue code
par code serait extrêmement bénéfique
pour l'adaptation du droit en lien
étroit avec le chaque territoire la
quatrième piste d'amélioration des
politiques publiques ce serait la
co-construction des politiques pour
réussir cette action et être conduite
par les territoires et pas à Paris ça
implique une déconcentration massive de
l'État autour du préfet ça a été
d'ailleurs le message du président
Larcher lors de sa visite en Guadeloupe
et en Martinique les outre-mer
pourraient être de ce point de vue
peut-être un champ d'expérimentation
pour la déconcentration une
déconcentration renforcée la cinquième
piste qu'on a imaginé
c'est vous savez qu'en outre-mer il
existe pour l'article 73 des procédures
d'habilitation législatives qui ne
fonctionnent pas aujourd'hui et on
aimerait que l'État puisse accompagner
les collectivités dans la mise en oeuvre
de ce processus qui reste un travail
législatif malgré tout et certaines
collectivités ne sont pas outillées pour
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre ses procédures
d'habitation qui par ailleurs ne
fonctionne pas extrêmement bien il faut
bien le reconnaître on a vous verrez
dans le rapport quand il sera rendu
public quelques pistes d'amélioration
également des habilitation il est enfin
par ailleurs indispensable de renforcer
les moyens de la dgom qui sont les
services administratifs du ministère des
Outre-mer je crois qu'en 2020 on OTP on
devait être à 137 TP à la dgem et je
crois que le cabinet du ministre ils
étaient 65 c'est des chiffres que j'ai
en tête donc ça vous donne le ratio
quand même du poids et depuis que je
suis rentré en politique en 2006 quand
j'étais Président je crois qu'on a perdu
plus de 90 de TP au ministère de manière
générale donc il y a une des perditions
quand même et donc le la dgom n'assure
plus le rôle de pilotage qu'elle
pourrait avoir dans le pilotage des
politiques publiques d'outre-mer donc ce
scénario statu quo a plusieurs avantages
évidemment il évite de réouvrir un débat
localement porteur de division sur
certains territoires
il contraint aussi l'état écoactivité à
inventer quelque part leur relation de
partenaires plutôt que de s'épuiser dans
des institutionnels il faut être honnête
on voit bien qu'il y a quand même un
certain nombre de pistes qui
mériteraient d'être creusé mais ce
scénario a aussi des faiblesses parce
qu'il ne permet pas de répondre aux
aspirations notamment de nos collègues
de la Guyane de la Martinique en faveur
d'un pouvoir normatif plus autonome
tout en restant dans l'article 73 enfin
ce n'est pas faire un Jura à personne
que de dire que il est permis quand même
de douter assez sincèrement de la
capacité de l'État à modifier en
profondeur et durablement c'est pratique
et son organisation je pense qu'il y a
une lucidité également qui est partagée
me semble-t-il sur ce constat-là et le
message en politique en direction des
Outre-mer serait faible le deuxième
scénario serait la révision des articles
73 et 74
alors cette option consisterait
finalement à les compléter
respectivement par plusieurs
dispositions
donc en fait on élargirait quelque part
j'ai envie de dire chaque article ça
aurait l'avantage d'éviter le reproche
premièrement de l'immobilisme
sans ouvrir un grand débat
institutionnel mais ça aurait quand même
des inconvénients le principal étant de
brouiller le cadre institutionnel depuis
la réforme constitutionnelle en 2003
finalement il y a eu une différence
entre les territoires ultramarins qui
c'est un peu érodé au niveau du statut
et donc effectivement si on élargit
chacun des deux articles concernés bon
on est encore un petit peu cette
différenciation mais on la on préserve
malgré tout je pense un certain
équilibre alors plusieurs modifications
nous paraissent quand même souhaitable
dans ce cadre là premièrement c'est
réécrire le second alinéa c'est purement
légitime mais pas que du préambules de
la Constitution pour supprimer la
mention anachronique au territoire
d'outre-mer qui est un héritage quand
même maintenant un peu passé
la deuxième modification qui pourrait
avoir lieu c'est le principe de
l'adaptation des normes aux réalités des
territoires qui pourraient être
renforcés en prévoyant une obligation
d'adapter
sauf à justifier la non nécessité d'une
adaptation aujourd'hui c'est
l'adaptation qui finalement est une
simple faculté
et qui doit être justifié et donc
l'étude d'impact de notre point de vue
ça pourrait être le document mettre dans
le cadre de ce travail donc on inverse
quelque part la charge de la preuve pour
justifier la note d'adaptation du droit
en outre-mer troisième mesure qui
pourrait être proposée dans ce cadre là
c'est d'ouvrir aux collectivités de
l'article 73 la possibilité d'exercer un
pouvoir normatif autonome c'est une
faculté pourrait prendre la forme d'une
extension permanente des habilitations
préalablement obtenues sous réserve que
le statut du territoire prévoit et qu'il
y ait eu un consentement de la
population malgré tout les populations
sont très sensibles à ces sujets et ce
sont des sujets qui parfois leur font
peur
quatrièmement si on peut voir normatif
autonome était admis pour ses
collectivités de Mondeuses évidemment un
amendement vira poulet modifié qui est
exclurait la réunion de ce dispositif
serait imaginable pour faire en sorte de
préserver l'équilibre sur le territoire
l'objectif d'une certainement pas
d'ouvrir le front d'une contestation
voire même d'une instrumentalisation
d'un sujet comme celui-ci alors qu'on
parle de politique publique au service
des populations
la Réunion pourrait de ce fait recourir
à la procédure d'habilitation qui
s'exerce sous contrôle du Parlement et
du gouvernement rappelons-le mais
continuerait à se distinguer parmi les
collectivités régies par article 73 on
s'interdisant tout pouvoir normatif
autonome voilà ce serait ce serait un
mode entre guillemets dégradé mais qui a
été souhaité à un moment donné par la
réunion et on imagine qu'aujourd'hui
l'évolution la disruption n'est pas tout
à fait du jour cinquièmement pour les
collectivités de l'article 74 le droit à
exercer toutes les compétences
aujourd'hui à son limitativement énuméré
dans nos lois organiques à l'exception
des compétences régaliennes et selon un
calendrier choisi par elle ça éviterait
des débats perturbutuels et voir sur
plusieurs années de modifications de loi
organique pour l'acquisition de
nouvelles compétences quand elle le
souhaiterait donc on rendrait quelque
part automatique en listant et puis ce
sont les collectivités qui
déclencheraient le moment venu la
volonté d'avoir un bloc de compétences
supplémentaire dans le cadre d'une
discussion avec évidemment l'État en
revanche il ne serait pas fait droit aux
demandes de mention particulière du
statut de certains territoires de la
Constitution et on pense notamment à la
Guyane et la Polynésie française de
l'autre point de vue ça c'est un champ
qu'on nous qu'on ne souhaite pas ouvrir
en tout cas la délégation n'a pas
souhaité ouvrir ce chemin le troisième
scénario qui est le scénario le plus
connu j'ai envie de dire c'est le cadre
constitutionnel rénové pour les autres
mères cette proposition rénovée par du
constat que la réforme constitutionnelle
de 2003 comme je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure à d'ores et déjà conduit à un
paysage institutionnel juridique un peu
éclaté en outre-mer qui brouille quelque
part les lignes de partage et ma
présence dans votre collectivité dans
votre délégation des montres
effectivement que cette lecture elle est
complexe parfois y compris pour les élus
et pour autant la distinction binaire
des articles 73 74 subsistent malgré
tout et prive les outre-mer de l'article
73 de l'accès à certains outils
juridiques qui sont réservés aux
collectivités de l'article 74
donc elle alimente aussi des crispations
sur la question des institutions la peur
de basculer dans une espèce d'enfer de
l'article 74 on voit bien qu'il y a
quand même ça peut être instrumentalisé
et la peur peut inquiéter les
populations au détriment d'ailleurs
d'une approche extrêmement pragmatique
de l'efficacité des politiques publiques
dès lors le cadre unifié aurait
plusieurs avantages donc ce serait la
réécriture des deux articles qu'on
ferait dans un seul chapeau il serait
assimilable à une forme de boîte à
outils au sein de laquelle chaque
outre-mer viendrait puiser ce qu'il
l'intéresse pour adapter son statut sur
mesure donc on aurait finalement une
disparition des articles 73 74 qui ne
constituerait pas l'absorption de l'un
des régimes par l'autre mais bien une
réécriture complète pour ouvrir le champ
des possibles ce serait la seule
condition pour que ça puisse fonctionner
de nos points de vue de d'ouvrir le
champ des possibles mais le scénario
numéro 3 qui est juridiquement et
intellectuellement le plus satisfaisant
je le dis également puisqu'en 2020 il
m'avait déjà convaincu
doit encore convaincre c'est l'un des
écueils majeur du scénario numéro 3
aujourd'hui travail de pédagogie devrait
être amplifié on confond souvent dans
les territoires réformes
constitutionnels réforme
institutionnelle les acteurs économiques
par exemple nous disent que pour eux une
réforme institutionnelle n'aurait aucune
conséquence voire même pourraient ouvrir
des craintes plutôt que d'améliorer la
conduite des politiques publiques sur
les territoires donc il faut entendre
également ce discours et dans nos cas de
nos auditions nous avons d'ailleurs
entendu les acteurs économiques pour
avoir cette vision également du terrain
ça nous paraissait important de ne pas
avoir qu'un débat autocentré entre les
élus je pense que ça n'a pas grand
intérêt et pour convaincre et rassurer
on imagine trois garanties au moins
préalable et indispensable la première
garantie ce serait que ce nouveau cadre
ne s'appliquerait pas aux drum donc
département région qui souhaitent
continuer à être régis par article 73
oui les gens qu'on commence à rentrer
dans dans une espèce de dichotomie qu'on
continue de maintenir historiquement
pour pour préserver les équilibre on est
fait cet article ne serait abrogé de 73
que pour chaque territoire concerné qu'a
compté la date de l'entrée en vigueur de
leur organique du nouveau statut
donc si vous ne voulez pas nouveau
statut finalement vous restez régi par
article 73 alors qu'on a réécrit quand
même l'article 73 74 voilà en deuxième
lieu il convient de marteler le fait que
ce nouveau statut ne crée pas
d'obligation d'évoluer
institutionnellement ça c'est un écueil
majeur on a beaucoup entendu c'est on a
le sentiment qu'on nous met quelque part
on nous pousse à une évolution si on
réécrit les deux articles ça n'est pas
tout à fait le cas en troisième lieu ce
cadre renforcerait le principe de
consultation et de l'approbation
populaire qui nous paraît indispensable
avant toute évolution institutionnelle
substantielle c'est une condition
sinequanone même si c'est débats
institutionnels sont parfois compliqués
et complexes à comprendre par les
populations parce qu'elles sont plus
intéressées à savoir comment vivre à la
fin et comment payer ses courses que de
savoir comment l'institution fonctionne
donc c'est garanti politique juridique
et démocratique sont des préalables
indispensables pour lever les
oppositions à une nouvelle page
constitutionnelle de nos points de vue
si elle doit s'ouvrir j'ai bien si elle
doit s'ouvrir et si elle s'ouvre
les trois scénarios qui viennent de vous
être présentés ont leurs avantages et
leurs faiblesses et donc on a délégation
on n'a pas souhaité trancher
définitivement ce sujet parce qu'on n'a
pas identifié ligne de crête dans
l'hypothèse ou une révision de la
Constitution serait bien l'ordre du jour
et on ne le sait pas encore aujourd'hui
la délégation a écarté le statu quo
constitutionnel on considérant que cette
perspective n'était pas satisfaisante et
elle s'est prononcée en faveur d'une
révision constitutionnelle pour ouvrir
champ des possibles on les sent ouvrir
les deux scénarios numéro 2 et numéro 3
ce qui nous paraît le plus sage
aujourd'hui de notre point de vue en
l'état actuel de nos connaissances mais
vous voyez depuis 2020 les choses ont
bougé et elles peuvent encore bouger
vraisemblablement en 2020 Michel Magra
avait porté le scénario numéro 3 qui
avait été retenu d'ailleurs par la
proposition numéro 44 et si la force de
cette proposition évidemment de Michel
demeure intacte de par sa cohérence et
son pragmatisme il faut aussi admettre
que les conditions d'un consensus dans
les territoires autour de celle-ci ne
sont pas aujourd'hui réunis c'est ce que
je vous disais en préambule on identifie
bien les causes on a du mal à identifier
des réponses précises pour tout le monde
et malgré son érosion cette distinction
entre les articles 73 74 demeure quand
même un point de repère assez fort
il y a peut-être plus important
effectivement à régler il ne faut pas le
nier le risque d'une incompréhension sur
la proposition d'un cadre
constitutionnel abolisant les abolissons
les catégories d'hommes comme reste
malgré tout élevés donc le à ce stade le
scénario numéro 3 nous paraît prématuré
dans le contexte politique actuel je
mets cette précautions d'usage il était
pertinent en 2020 aujourd'hui on est un
peu plus prudent et c'est cette
préconisation que j'ai une honneur de
faire hier au groupe décentralisation et
puisqu'on est dans l'actualité
ultramarine bouillonnante au-delà du
contexte électif de dimanche hier le
ministre caraco a réuni les deux
délégations de l'Assemblée le matin et
du Sénat l'après-midi outre-mer pour
évoquer le sium à l'issue en fait de la
réunion avec le président de la
République le 7 septembre monsieur
Darmanin qui a un coup ont adressé des
courriers à tous les préfets en disant
voilà les thèmes que nous souhaitons
aborder dans le cadre d'un travail
participatif avec les collectivités et
les partenaires des territoires on a
huitième identifié et le 9e n'arrivera
que si il est nécessaire d'y arriver et
le neuvième thème c'est la réforme
institutionnelle donc autrement dit on
balaie d'abord toutes les conditions de
vie les conditions de développement
économique ce qui ne fonctionne pas sur
les territoires et on aboutit seulement
à une évolution institutionnelle si on
la juge nécessaire et indispensable le
ministre nous indique hier que la date
du Siam avait été au 12 juin prochain
qu'à peu près plus de 2000 demandes
émaner des territoires dans le cadre du
somme c'est un peu la boîte de Pandore
il y a certains et ça a été un appel
d'air quand même considérable ça a été
synthétisé a priori autour d'une
centaine de propositions avec différents
vecteurs que vous connaissez sur les le
bien-être des populations les facteurs
économiques etc et puis le volet
institutionnel sera traité à part donc
on imagine déjà que si le sium répond à
un certain nombre de critiques ou de
dysfonctionnements il n'est pas certain
que le champ institutionnel ou
constitutionnel en tout cas soit ouvert
pour autant un territoire qui dispose
aujourd'hui du noir chronique pourrait
effectivement engager un processus avec
le gouvernement pour réviser à la marge
s'il le souhaitait ce cette loi Oran
Nicolas quelles sont nos conclusions et
je me tiens évidemment à votre
disposition pour tous les éclairages
mais vous le verrez c'est un peu plus
détaillé complet dont le rapport
j'essaie de faire une synthèse même si
vous avez compris vraisemblablement
qu'il y a une complexité certaine et
puis annexer astrapore on a également
mis collectivité par collectivité les
synthèses des auditions qui vous permet
d'avoir une vision précise de ce qu'on
leur a demandé voulez-vous un pouvoir
normatif voulez-vous restituer des
compétences à l'état vous voulez vous
prendre des compétences à l'état donc on
a vraiment fait un travail et merci à la
délégation d'avoir fait ce travail
considérable de synthèse qui permet
d'avoir une vision transversale assez
précise de la situation actuelle encore
une fois qui va évoluer puisque dimanche
le scrutin par exemple en Polynésie va
faire évoluer puisque dans le programme
politique de l'équipe qui va être
installée vraisemblablement que mon
homologue de l'assemblée moteurson sera
élu président on
identifie déjà des évolutions
institutionnelles au-delà du volet
indépendance j'entends je dis déjà que
sur volet institutionnel il y aura
vraisemblablement un champ un peu
différent de celui qui a été auditionné
jusqu'ici donc c'est une manière assez
vivante et le gouvernement je l'espère
sera prendre la mesure en tout cas le
Sénat lui et là pour aussi accompagner
nos collègues des collectivités qui
souhaiteront un moment donné ou pas
évoluer de manière statutaire
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
pour ce travail considérable et la
méthode qui a été la vôtre c'est-à-dire
l'écoute de tous les territoires
l'envie de en tout cas où le souhaite
d'aboutir à un diagnostic partagé
et de pointer des possibles nous aimons
beaucoup ici le même langage que le
vôtre sert le champ des possibles
puisque nous sommes convaincus que sur
les territoires la marque c'est en
quelque sorte la différence et
l'identité du territoire au sens positif
et que la loi doit donner un cadre de
poussi pour œuvrer pour des solutions
alors moi j'ai beaucoup aimé ce que vous
avez dit sur le fait que contrairement à
cette ce qui est souvent une manie
française
où on essaie de définir un cadre en
disant oui on a bien identifié des
difficultés d'ailleurs on les a
identifié de manière plus ou moins
complète mais on va faire un cadre et le
cadre va créer le miracle du bon
fonctionnement or vous le dites et vous
l'affirmez moi je m'en réjouis que
l'évolution des institutions vient après
une fois qu'on a
identifié les dysfonctionnements les
besoins les services à rendre et que
l'on a aussi un projet et le président
buffet l'a dit hier dans la question
gouvernement quel est le projet que nous
avons pour les outre-mer mais ce projet
c'est pas le projet un projet vertical
de la France ou de la métropole ou
d'institutions pour des territoires
d'outeux mais ce doit être un projet
partagé vous avez beaucoup insisté
là-dessus sur l'adhésion de la
population donc ce premier point sur
le cadre institutionnel qui n'a rien de
d'urgence en tout cas c'est pas la
première chose nous va bien le deuxième
point c'est ce que vous pointez et ce
qui sous-tend
à la fois les situations que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui un peu modifié et
qui sont proposés l'objectif qui est
l'efficacité de l'action publique c'est
refaire que les populations centre
guillemets servis au sens positif que
l'égalité des droits soient une réalité
et que ces territoires puissent
connaître un dynamisme qui soit
adapté alors possibilité et soutenue et
qu'il y ait cette solidarité
nationale évidemment et on constate et
dans ce que vous avez appelé le premier
scénario on retrouve vous l'avez dit les
travaux ou les conclusions des travaux
de la délégation de deux rapports
solides Agnès canae ericaouche qui parle
des services déconcentrés de l'État et
on voit bien que en outre-mer comme chez
nous les collectivités sont amenées
parfois
à se débrouiller sans ligne générer et
sans la pluie a fortiori comme il y a
une diminution des des services et que
on a un dysfonctionnement
de méthode puisque les études d'impact
vous l'avez aussi elles ne sont pas
faites elles n'existent pas et que
parfois on n'a pas été assez ambitieux
en matière d'expérimentation vous l'avez
dit puisque je crois que
l'expérimentation permet de tester des
choses permettre d'apprivoiser aussi des
changements qui sont nécessaires de
corriger c'est-à-dire de s'engager vers
des évolutions de manière sécurisée un
peu comment montagne on a trois points
trois points d'appui voilà je ne serai
pas plus longue sur le sur le sujet
avant de laisser mes collègues
vous vous
interrogez mais en tout cas voilà
c'était cet échange et pour nous je
pense extrêmement important pour que
l'on puisse dans les travaux nous sentir
partie prenante des discussions qui peut
y parce que nous sommes nés juste la
terre et qu'à un moment dans la vie
émettre Jean-Michel peut-être
parce que tu as un air Polynésie assez
frais mais pas que oui j'ai pas mon
dossier polynésien mais j'ai quelque
chose dans la tête d'abord remercier et
remercier Stéphane pour pour comment
dire le travail qui a été accompli les
trois scénarios qui ne sont proposés
dans lequel c'est vrai à la lueur de ce
que nous avons vécu et ce que nous avons
découvert en Polynésie on retrouve un
certain nombre de choses puisque on nous
a parlé on nous a dit écoutez souvent
nous demande notre avis on nous demande
notre avis c'est trop tard
dans la mesure où la loi elle est déjà
passée et et on en tient donc pas compte
et on se demande à quoi on sert
sur la nécessité de co-construire
d'avoir de la déconcentration de la part
de l'État sur le pouvoir normatif
autonome tout ça bien évidemment on l'a
retrouvé la Polynésie donc tu l'as dit
donc article 74 avec quand même une
particularité c'est que la géographie
s'impose et quand la géographie s'impose
c'est-à-dire c'est de mémoire 118 il 48
communes réparties sur un territoire
grand comme l'Europe donc ce qui entre
guillemets sur le plan notamment du
découpage institutionnel pose quelques
difficultés donc on a on a bien vu qu'il
y avait une nécessité peut-être de
toilettage à la fois sur le périmètre
des communes puisque vous avez des îles
qui sont rattachés à des communes comme
commune associées et pour lequel le
conseil municipal ne peut pas se réunir
dans de bonnes conditions parce que il
faut quasiment deux jours pour rejoindre
la commune mère si on peut dire on a
aussi des intercommunalités dont le
découpage se pose voilà on peut se poser
la question qui sont plus des
opportunités parfois financières on ne
veut pas de tel
île parce que on va dépasser le seuil et
on aura une allocation inférieure et
ainsi de suite donc là aussi peut-être
quelque chose à revoir et puis on a
senti aussi qui avait besoin
d'innovation et ce besoin d'innovation
chantez-vous allait un peu ce qui sera
les conclusions de notre rapport mais ce
besoin d'innovation on a senti que les
Archipels était des entités qui étaient
des entités à la fois géographiques
sociologiques extrêmement forte
c'est-à-dire qu'entre d'un côté les
Australes où il y a une culture qui est
différente de celle des îles du Vent ou
des îles sous le vent ou des toits
moutoux et en plus c'est vrai quand on
parle des Marquises même pour ceux qui
connaissent pas les Marquises on
s'imagine que les Marquis ça reste dans
le monde polynésien et mélanésien
comment dirais-je une entité culturelle
extrêmement forte extrêmement
extrêmement particulière on a pointé des
choses nous sur l'exercice des
compétences et avec je dirais des des
focales un peu particulières sur le
cycle de l'eau et peut-être sans doute
une adaptation normative extrêmement
importante dans la mesure où on sait
très bien que l'eau est très rare
notamment dans les toits moto qu'il faut
récupérer le pluie mais à partir du
moment où on collectivement on récupère
de l'eau de pluie est-ce qu'elle devient
de l'eau potable et ainsi de suite donc
il y a toute cette problématique
d'adaptation par rapport à des normes
sur la totalité de l'eau de même en
matière d'assainissement on a vu que que
l'assainissement était un petit peu
comment dirais-je parfois défaillant et
qui avait un gros déficit de contrôle
notamment sur la qualité des eaux de
baignades donc vous avez des systèmes
qui sont des systèmes des écosystèmes
fermés comme les lagons dans lequel se
déverse malheureusement souvent des
résidus d'assainissement qui peuvent et
qui ne sont faut le reconnaître peu
contrôler ou quasiment pas contrôlés ou
quand ils le sont on ferme les yeux
parce que ça peut avoir des incidences
c'est-à-dire que c'est vrai qu'en
métropole quand vous avez un arrêté
d'interdiction de baignade dans une zone
touristique ça peut ça peut être
catastrophique on a pointé aussi la
problématique des déchets et ça donc les
ordures ménagères et tout ce qui
s'ensuit donc ce qui veut dire en clair
que ça va être ma question suivante
c'est que donc ça nécessite peut-être à
la fois une innovation sur l'exercice
des compétences en fonction de la
géographie
ça nécessite sans doute peut-être aussi
un certain nombre de de toilettage
institutionnels et puis c'est vrai vous
tu l'as dit il y a la géographie mais
maintenant il y a un fait politique
le fait que le parti de ce quartier Maru
et je veux dire est remporté 38 sièges
sur 58 c'est qu'il a désormais
maintenant la majorité et qu'il y a une
volonté entre guillemets d'évolution
alors comment comment les choses vont se
traduire
je terminerai par un peu par une
question parce qu'il y a une fonction
qui nous paraît moi qui me paraît
importante c'est la fonction comment
dirais-je de contrôle et
d'accompagnement
quand je dis contrôle et
d'accompagnement on a une chambre c'est
la chambre territoriale des comptes etc
qui exerce qui exerce sa mission de
contrôle
elle a un contrôle à postériori moi je
pense qu'il y a un déficit
d'accompagnement amont alors peut-être
relié par rapport à la formation
peut-être par rapport au Conseil et de
façon à accompagner je dirais les
territoires et les décideurs dans
l'efficience de l'action publique je
vais très prudent dans mes termes mais
mais on voit bien que parfois on a dans
des territoires notamment en Polynésie
un manque de stratégie dans la location
de moyens pour pas dire que l'antilisme
manque de stratégie dans la location de
moyens donc comment faire en sorte que
on puisse accompagner les décideurs dans
peut-être l'Efficient de la location des
moyens qui sont effectués donc
l'auto-évaluation et ainsi de suite donc
le plus en amont possible ce qui évite
ensuite par des déconvenus des contenus
qui font souvent malheureusement la une
de l'actualité et qui dégrade entre
guillemets l'image que l'on peut avoir
des outre-mer et aussi bien évidemment
la présence de l'État dans les outre-mer
dans ces missions donc moi la question
c'est moi je souscris un peu je dirais
c'est vrai que le troisième scénario va
me sembler excusez-moi mais un peu
s'imposer quand même parce qu'on sent
qu'il va y avoir une forte pression de
la part du du soit du président de
l'Assemblée territoriale ou soit du du
président de la Polynésie mais on sent
très bien qu'il y a un souhait
d'évolution donc il va falloir s'y
préparer d'une certaine façon et ma
question donc est-ce que vous avez
envisagé donc une évolution justement
des fonctions de contrôle la façon dont
l'État peut être mieux présent dans ses
collectivités pour mieux les accompagner
on peut prendre on peut prendre d'autres
questions oui encore une je t'en prie
merci tout d'abord et bien je voulais
vous remercier te remercier madame le
Président d'avoir initié ce point ici en
délégation aux collectivités locales et
puis remercier Stéphane pour un
présentation du rapport c'est
extrêmement intéressant vraiment merci
beaucoup et peut-être me permettre de
faire un témoignage je veux dire de
témoigner aussi de ce que j'ai pu voir
et rencontrer en Martinique il y a dix
jours maintenant je crois j'étais dans
une délégation de la commission des
affaires sociales
où nous nous sommes déplacés pour la
question du vieillissement de la
population un département qui sera d'ici
les années d'ici 2030 le département le
plus vieux de France puisque les
personnes âgées de plus de 75 ans seront
plus nombreuses que celles âgés de moins
de 25 ans donc c'est un vrai sujet et
quand on parle et je rebondis aussi sur
les propos de Jean-Michel
l'état mieux présent dans ces
territoires je pense que aussi pour la
Martinique j'ai envie de dire les choses
s'imposent aussi nous avons rencontré
une devise présidente de la collectivité
territoriale Martinique puisque
maintenant on est sur un Drôme donc
département région pour la Martinique
nous avons également pu rencontrer un
des trois présidents
des trois intercos de Martinique et puis
plusieurs mères des 34 communes dit ça
parce que voilà on est sur un territoire
aussi très particulier et des
spécificités des départements
d'outre-mer et puis vous avez et
Jean-Michel a développé sur la Polynésie
mais même si la Martinique est plus
petite il n'empêche que le Nord et le
Sud et le centre on va dire c'est pas la
même chose et les problématiques sont
pas les mêmes et en termes de
compétences aussi de cette nouvelle
collectivité territoriale si
particulière là aussi les questions se
posent un vrai besoin dans le domaine
social qui fait comment faire avec les
autres collectivités dans le domaine
social c'est pas seulement l'action
sociale mais puisque je vous parlais du
vieillissement c'est quid de la prise en
charge de ces personnes âgées
dans un territoire encore une fois très
divers du nord au sud avec une question
concernant la mobilité qui est vraiment
là comment on va dire très
primordial les grosses difficultés de
déplacement du nord au sud et autour de
Fort-de-France l'accès aux soins aussi
je disais la prise en charge de ces
personnes
âgées ou vieillissantes les EHPAD qui
sont là aussi voilà dans dans un vrai
sujet et les moyens que l'État peut
donner consacrer ce territoire
si je reviens sur l'aspect santé dans le
cadre du Ségur de la santé certes et
moyen important parce que les moyens
sont attendus en tout cas les besoins
sont extrêmement importants mais même si
c'est moyen sont importants en termes
d'investissement ils sont aujourd'hui
demain ils seront insuffisants donc
j'apprécie aussi ce que tu as dit
Stéphane donc la façon dont sur la
méthode les choses s'organisent on parle
d'abord on regarde d'abord les
problématiques de ces départements en
termes sociales économique aménagement
du territoire et à la fin s'il faut une
révision un aménagement une évolution de
l'institution voire de la Constitution
ça pourrait être évoqué je pense que la
vie au quotidien en général
dans ce département que je ne
connaissais pas que j'ai visité donc
très récemment elle est aussi à prendre
en considération dans les évolutions
qui s'imposent au-delà de l'actualité
aussi très criante sur d'autres
départements qu'on connaît tous on voit
bien que il y a une nécessité absolue de
prendre en compte ses besoins ses
attentes très fortes de la population
comme des acteurs locaux qui soient
politiques ou économique voir associatif
puisque c'était aussi en Martinique
aussi un secteur très développé voilà je
voulais me permettre de faire ce petit
témoignage en complément de ce que vous
avez pu dire les uns les autres
cher Stéphane si tu veux peut-être
répondre à ce d'abord répondre aux
témoignages de Corinne pour venir dire
que c'est je crois que c'est la deuxième
fois maintenant que la commission des
affaires sociales se déplace en
outre-mer je crois qu'elle y était allée
une première fois me semble-t-il en
Guyane
voilà et vous dire à toutes et tous
qu'il est extrêmement important
qu'on maintienne ces déplacements en
outre-mer des commissions et des
délégations du Sénat parce que vous
n'avez pas idée de ce que vous y
découvrez enfin je pense que ton
témoignage est assez révélateur et moi
je me souviens du témoignage d'un ami
long qui s'était rendu en Guyane et qui
m'avait parlé de l'acheminement pour la
Guyane des matériels médicaux par avion
et les difficultés que ça posait je
pourrais aussi lui parler de mon
territoire y compris des évacuations
sanitaires sur Rennes en cas d'oncologie
etc enfin et vraiment d'aller sur ces
territoires comme d'aller dans chacun de
vos territoires d'ailleurs nous permet
évidemment de nous rendre compte de
l'inadaptation de certains dispositifs
et surtout des réalité auquel nous
sommes confrontés qui sont parfois
insurmontables donc merci de ce
témoignage est vraiment insisté pour
dire que nous on plaide évidemment pour
que le maximum de parlementaires
puissent se rendre dans le ces
territoires et merci à votre délégation
d'avoir pris soin d'être à la Polynésie
pour traiter ce sujet intercommunalité
et pour essayer de répondre aux
questions en mettant un peu plus large
sur sur la Polynésie de dire finalement
la redistribution de compétences sur le
territoire à toujours été un sujet
notamment de la part des communes
puisque elles ont des capacités
d'investissement qui sont assez limitées
et donc finalement elles ont une
aspiration évidemment à pouvoir répondre
à leur à leurs obligations à cet égard
et donc ce sujet là il n'est pas nouveau
et d'ailleurs quand on a auditionné le
président Fritsch en 2022 il déclarait
être ouvert à des discussions pour un
nouveau partage de compétences il disait
dès le début de mon mandat de président
en septembre 2014 j'ai proposé à tous
les meilleurs sont distinction
d'appartenance politique de considérer
le pays comme un partenaire de
développement j'ai mis en place des
outils différencier innovant en faveur
de projets d'investissement communaux
aujourd'hui les conditions sont devenues
favorables et permettent une évolution
en faveur d'une plus grande coopération
entre la Polynésie et les communes en
fait il y a trois outils de coopération
qui existent déjà
dans Polynésie française et qui ne
nécessite pas forcément une modification
organique vous avez la possibilité pour
la Polynésie de confier aux communes par
mandat d'un champ de compétences vous
avez possibilité
d'utiliser la voix de la délégation et
enfin vous avez la possibilité du
transfert de compétences dans les
conditions définies par la Polynésie
française donc en fait il y a déjà des
outils qui existent aujourd'hui et je
pense que le problème qui a été
confronté et sur les déchets quand on a
fait le rapport sur les déchets
récemment on s'en est aussi rendu compte
il y a une aspiration des mers
polynésiens d'ailleurs qui a été
exprimée lors du de l'après-midi
consacrée au Sénat de dire finalement
nous on a des compétences qu'on n'arrive
pas à assumer aujourd'hui et dans le
sentiment que le pays ne nous aide pas
suffisamment il y avait une volonté de
restituer cette compétence sauf à
disposer des moyens financiers qui leur
permettaient de pouvoir assurer le
traitement donc la situation des des
communes est évidemment propre à ce
territoire il y a également la question
de la fiscalité qui vient percuter
l'exercice des compétences sur sur les
sur le territoire polynésiens puisque
fiscalement les communes comme souvent
non assez peu de marge de manœuvre à
l'inverse on a identifié nous dont nos
réflexions des marges de manœuvre mais
on vous apprendra à rien en vous disant
que notamment pour les communes
touristiques avec la taxe de séjour qui
pourrait être peut-être mieux mobilisé
au mieux orienter vraisemblablement qui
pourrait y avoir une marge avec la
nécessité de maintenir malgré tout une
péréquation entre les communes qui
fonctionnent bien et celles qui ont
moins de capacités financières et cette
péréquation peut parfois être perçue de
manière
inéquitable ou injuste pour la commune
qui fonctionne bien par rapport à celle
qui en a besoin et voilà ça c'est quand
même l'expression même de la solidarité
mais c'est pas mais ce que je dis là je
pense que voilà on le rencontre un peu
partout ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
absolument sur l'INT
[Musique]
qui parfois l'insularité nous pousse à
l'innovation je pense que dire certains
contextes ou de même de ruralité j'ai
envie de dire qu'il nous pousse dans nos
territoires à être plus créatif parce
que finalement on est quasiment entre
guillemets un peu seul au monde et
contrainte se débrouiller et je suis
persuadé que il y a des solutions qui
pourront être trouvées
au-delà au-delà du caractère
indépendantiste de l'élection qui a eu
lieu dimanche moteurson qui est je
considère quelqu'un de modéré à la
volonté de continuer à dialoguer que le
gouvernement ministre karako nous a
confirmé également la volonté de vouloir
avancer et effectivement il y aura toute
une un panel je pense de réponse qui
devront être identifiées pour
l'adaptation comme je le disais sur les
lois les normes etc la Polynésie dispose
vraiment d'un large pouvoir d'autonomie
elle peut déjà utiliser ce pouvoir
normatif mais elle dispose peut-être
assez peu d'accompagnement c'est ce que
tu disais sur notamment en matière de
contrôle et c'est vrai que l'enjeu pour
la Polynésie comme pour d'autres
territoires d'ailleurs
ultramarins et pas que ultramarin c'est
comment comment se saisir pleinement des
compétences qui nous sont confiées et je
peux parler aussi de mon territoire on a
le la même thématique par contre sur le
volet du contrôle qui a été évoqué il y
a deux choses que je voudrais dire c'est
que il faut aussi renvoyer l'État c'est
responsabilités
je dis très librement l'état parfois ne
fait pas son travail de contrôle sur
certains territoires dans certains
domaines et je crois que le contrôle
opéré par l'État c'est aussi une
protection pour les élus
on le dit pas assez mais je pense qu'il
faut le dire le contrôle a posteriori de
la chambre territoriale des comptes dont
le processus législatif qui a été
modifié par la suite moi je sais que par
exemple sur mon territoire on a
l'obligation une fois qu'un rapport de
la chambre est fait de faire un rapport
de suite présenté et mis en débat à
l'Assemblée pour indiquer les réponses
apportées aux remarques de la chambre
territoriale des comptes donc ce n'est
pas seulement des réponses adresses à la
chambre c'était également aussi
publiquement et je trouve je ne sais pas
si ça existe en Polynésie ça existe en
tout cas à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon je
pense que ça devrait exister en
Polynésie mais c'est un point sur lequel
peut-être il faudrait regarder un peu
les choses peut-être un point à creuser
parce que je n'ai pas cette compétence
sincèrement sur cet aspect en
particulier mais effectivement la
fonction de contrôle en amont est
indispensable pour sécuriser les
pratiques je pense que là aussi et il y
a il y a un vrai besoin d'accompagnement
et ce qu'on parle d'État déconcentré
plus fort c'est dans cette mission
d'accompagnement des collect
dit toujours on est là on est là
accompagnateur
on passe souvent l'état accompagnateur
et facilitateur faut être honnête quoi
parfois on a l'impression on a
l'impression que sur certains
territoires certaines administrations
sont tellement pléthoriques qu'elles
sont surtout là pour chacun exister ou
chacune existait et ramener des
barrières sur un dossier qui finalement
autour d'une table trouve des solutions
dans un cadre réglementaire qui
respectait et je trouve que là on manque
d'intelligence collective à un moment
donné et c'est ça le changement des
méthodes aussi vous savez ne serait-ce
que de faire participer parfois des
services de l'état des réflexions de
territoire à des projets de
développement économique on change de
logiciel les fonctionnaires des actes
qui me le disent et je leur en veux pas
parce qu'ils nous disent mais nous on
n'a pas été formés pour travailler sur
des projets économiques de territoire
les fonctionnaires d'État on est là pour
faire en sorte que la loi s'applique que
les procédures soient respectées quand
on leur dit mais vous êtes au service
d'un territoire vous êtes au service de
votre pays mais aussi d'un territoire et
comment est-ce qu'on fait collectivement
pour pousser les murs
et ça ce changement de méthode il est
pas naturel il dépend beaucoup des
hommes et des femmes qui sont au monde
je le dis parce que c'est une question
de leadership
on peut on peut moi Jean-François caraco
qui est ministre des Outre-mer il a
marqué mon territoire en 96 parce qu'il
a été un ministre un préfet il a marqué
mon téléphone on parle de 96 vous en
parler aujourd'hui on vous cite un
préfet on va vous citer je ressens parce
que les méthodes ont permis au
territoire d'avancer et je pense que
c'est ce qu'on attend également l'état
sans nos territoires quand on parle d'un
état déconcentré recentrer sur ses
fonctions avec une reprise en main de
certains Jason sur lesquelles on a perdu
le contrôle l'ADEME l'OSB entre autres
en cet sujet qu'on a évoqué à plusieurs
reprises la NCT qui on espère devrait
prendre corps en outre-mer et on peine
en peine un peu quand même avoir comment
ça se formalise on a l'impression que
c'est le préfet qui est directeur de la
NCT chaque territoire mais finalement il
est assez peu de mise à disposition des
collectivités donc le champ est quand
même très ouvert et effectivement au
bout du bout je suis assez d'accord on
arrive vraisemblablement on voulait
constitutionnelle ou institutionnel si
vraiment on n'a pas réglé les problèmes
avant mais on a quand même un champ très
très important à régler me semble-t-il
par l'intelligence collective des gens
avant tout
peut-être
en écho à ce que tu dis est-ce que tu
disais Corinne sur
l'accès aux soins moi j'étais très
frappée en Polynésie
j'arrivais avec une idée enfin une idée
je pense que étant donné la
configuration le nombre d'îles les
distances qu'il y avait un vrai sujet
d'accès aux soins et que les déserts
médicaux pouvaient être là-bas
au milieu de l'océan une réalité et bien
nous avons rencontré quasiment tous les
mers Jean-Michel ça n'est jamais un
sujet qui a été émis soulevé mentionné
par les élus c'est nous qui l'avons
mentionné
et que comme tu l'as dit comme tu es sur
un territoire insulaire assez isolé
tu inventes des choses et tu as aussi
une certaine forme non pas de résilience
mais d'adaptation au contexte et les
médecins par exemple au marquis je le a
des mères nous disait nous on a une
sorte de dispensaire on a un peu de
médecin on a des infirmières etc il y a
ce qu'on appelle en justice enfin on
utilise le mot de justice foraine et là
on parle de médecine foraine puisque ils
font venir de manière assez régulière ou
séquencé depuis papeter de l'hôpital un
avion avec des spécialistes donc
l'oncologue le dermatologue voilà Vienne
reste quelques jours donc bien suivi de
la population qui ne crée pas en tout
cas d'anxiété oui moi ça m'a ça m'a
vraiment ça m'a vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup frappé et le deuxième
point c'est ce que tu évoqué Stéphane
autour de la subsidiarité c'est quel est
le meilleur niveau pour faire les choses
et vous avez évoqué deux sujets
Jean-Michel c'est celui des déchets et
c'est celui de l'eau potable et les
déchets sont un sujet majeur pour la
Polynésie parce que Jean-Michel l'a dit
bon à bon hein c'est une pépite
touristique de par la qualité de ses
eaux et que s'il y a dans ce dans ce
pays
des incidents de pollution l'effet
économique et l'effet en termes d'images
et des astres parce qu'une grande partie
de la clientèle touristique une
clientèle américaine
très sensible à ces sujets et que on a
vu qu'en fait en Polynésie les communes
n'ont pas de compétences générales elles
ont deux compétences qu'il aurait été
qu'il en était donnée
l'eau potable enfin et l'assainissement
et les déchets
alors que on a là-bas naturellement une
raréfaction de l'eau il n'y a pas de
compteur et il y a pas de on ne paye pas
l'eau et donc est-ce qu'on ne pense pas
qu'en fait le principe de solidarité
conduirait ce qu'il y ait à l'échelle de
la Polynésie un schéma de collecte et de
traitement des déchets si vous imaginez
que chaque île doit éliminer ses déchets
les envoyer enfin c'est assez hurissant
est-ce que c'est pas le pays qui devrait
et savait d'ailleurs été dit par la
délégation qui devrait avoir une
stratégie et permettre de mutualiser les
moyens et la stratégie et de même et de
même que l'eau alors que le pays a gardé
des compétences un peu de proximité donc
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il y a des
échelles qui sont nécessaires et qui
peuvent se faire bon faut faire bouger
la loi mais sans grande sans grande
révolution
sans grande révolution
institutionnelle et puis on retrouve je
pense à l'échelle du pays en fait de la
Polynésie ce que l'on connaît chez nous
c'est à la déconcentration la
co-construction c'est-à-dire à l'échelle
de la Polynésie ce contexte
vaste comme l'Europe il faut qu'il y ait
entre les communes des interco qui
existent et le pays de la
co-construction et de la proximité de
l'accompagnement quoi voilà
Jean-Michel qui permet juste un tout
petit complément c'est vrai qu'en
Polynésie dans le domaine de la santé il
n'y a pas il y a pas de problème dans le
domaine curatif si on peut dire
néanmoins il y a pas de politique de
santé publique il y a pas de politique
de santé publique avec deux gros deux
très très gros problèmes le problème
c'est des équilibres alimentaires avec
augmentation du diabète même maladie
cardiovasculaire etc lié souvent à
l'obésité sur quoi et puis le deuxième
c'est un phénomène nouveau qu'on a
découvert c'est celui des addictions
notamment des nouveaux composants
composés de drogues etc etc qui arrive
parce que la Polynésie est un territoire
extrêmement visité beaucoup beaucoup en
relation mais il y a pas de politique de
santé publique
[Musique]
Stéphane encore une fois vraiment merci
puisque je crois que c'était et pour
nous extrêmement intéressant enfin c'est
une ouverture
d'esprit un apport de connaissance pour
ce qui fait partie de notre fonction
voilà
en plus je sais le travail la grande
qualité du travail que tu as conduit à
la délégation avec ton équipe et les
administrateurs et ce que j'appelle
l'intelligence de ton propos
c'est-à-dire on est vraiment dans cette
attachement
aux outre-mer la volonté qu'il y ait
enfin il faut dire de la performance de
service public et qu'en même temps on
est bien dans une forme de lucidité dans
l'analyse en disant on ne peut pas
simplement se contenter de dire il y a
qu'à Foucault c'est la faute de etc mais
qu'il doit y avoir un vrai portage
politique et que nous législateurs nous
avons je crois un rôle essentiel dans
lequel nous devons nous investir pour
comprendre partager construire et
soutenir des démarches aussi positives
que la tienne cher Stéphane
merci cher présente merci de votre
invitation et merci vraiment de vos
travaux encore une fois je nous
militants mais je pense qu'on est tous
les deux des présidents convaincus de
délégation et notre Président nous a
donné des consignes très clairs et je
pense que c'est partagé par l'ensemble
des commissions un morceau de travail
croisé est vraiment extrêmement
important et fructueux et je me tiens
évidemment à vos dispositions on se
tient à vos dispositions à chaque fois
que vous en aurez besoin et je pensais à
la mission effectivement sur le service
des concentrés de l'État que vous avez
mené je me dis qu'un prolongement de
cette mission d'outre-mer
je pense que ça ait ça risquerait de
bousculer un certain nombre de choses
parce que on a calqué parfois la
réorganisation des services de l'État en
outre-mer a sauvons été calqué à celle
de l'hexagone et moi je me souviens
toujours d'un préfet qui me l'a présenté
et je lui disais mais vous êtes
complètement à côté de des clous et que
vous allez dans le mur aujourd'hui vous
envoyez votre administration et le
territoire dans le mur parce que vous
n'adaptez pas les services de l'État au
problématiques des territoires et donc
je pense que les réflexions que vous
mener vous seront extrêmement utiles en
tout cas merci beaucoup de cette de
cette invitation et c'est de la qualité
de ces échanges
merci le souhait que tu formules est
entendu et je crois avoir compris que
les collègues qui ont porté cette
réflexion ce service déconcentrés seront
aussi très heureux voilà de prolonger le
champ des investigations merci
cher Stéphane merci beaucoup
chers collègues vous n'êtes pas libéré
vous le savez vous voilà parce que là on
va parler à argent